hey guys Pete here is going to be
another Game of Thrones Season 7 video
primarily talking about what's coming up
in episode 3 but maybe a little bit more
down the road as well no real spoilers
said all this is just speculation based
on stuff I've been thinking about so
this should be fine for everyone it's
just going to talk about stuff we've
already seen so it's putting together
the last couple of videos I started
thinking about some other characters and
how they relate to my speculation about
Jon and Daenerys his first meeting you
know while reading the comments and
thinking about Jon and Daenerys not
hitting it off and all that started to
speculate about how things are going to
come together after that first meeting
and it brought up something I hadn't
really considered before in season 6
when Daenerys and Jorah Mormont away you
know commanding him to find a cure for
his greyscale it never really made a lot
of sense to me
it was a fine scene you know these two
characters have a history and all that's
fine it just seemed out of place and
everything else that was going on at the
time and like I said of course Jorah is
a character that we have all come to
care about that his place in the endgame
story wasn't exactly clear at this point
after that we've seen Daenerys leave
Essos and even her paramour Daario
naharis she left him behind without
appearing to bat an eyelash about him so
why was Jorah getting well so important
all of a sudden after all she had sent
him away after learning about his
betrayal and until recently didn't want
him anywhere near her so in all that
talk about Jon not bending the knee and
how their causes are totally different
and made me think about Jorah and why
he's still around we know that he ended
up at the Citadel in Old Town looking
for a cure he traveled a long way to get
there he's met Sam who has very good
reasons to want to help him we've
established those you know Joris father
was jor and that was Sam's Lord
Commander at the ball and he owes him
for saving his life on more than one
occasion real quick not to get off-track
too much but it should be mentioned that
is uncharted territory even if the books
were ahead of the show it wouldn't make
a difference here because Dora doesn't
have one never had greyscale in the
source material all the way around he's
quite a different character and that's
not really important except for the fact
that the juror we're following you know
Dan and Dave's version of Jorah is still
important enough that he seems to have a
purpose in getting to the end game of
the show so important they had him
receive a direct order from the Queen
who he not only serves but who he loved
in the most unrequited way imaginable
it's at the level of like unconditional
love at this point he'll never be with
her and he knows it but he will serve
her and even give his life for her
either way we know this about him her
cause is his cause bottom line whatever
she wants is whatever he wants she's
important to him he's important to the
showrunners Dan and Dave curing him is
important to Sam but why is all of this
important as a whole when we look at it
this way it sort of jumps out that Sam
will likely cure Dora's greyscale and
I'm guessing that this is going to
happen quickly as in he's probably going
to be getting well in Episode three or
at least on his way to I mean he might
be better in Episode three but he'll at
least he on his way to recovery
why do I feel confident that while he
what else is he there for and where will
he go when he recovers and that's the
easiest question to answer he's going to
go to Dragonstone to show his Khaleesi
that he's done what she's asked and this
is actually pretty key he's at the
Citadel with Sam who is one of the only
characters who's seen a white walk not
only as he seen one he killed it he is
at the Citadel trying to learn how to
beat the White Walkers and the army of
white if he passes this information on
the door which if you think about it why
wouldn't he I mean he's seen them more
than once you know he's basically one of
the most educated people about what a
threat they really are so yeah why
wouldn't he tell Jorah all about this
especially in relation to jours father
then later on down the road or arrives
at Dragonstone and he has a purpose
beyond getting well you know not he
doesn't just need to get well he also
needs to deliver this information and
that information could go a long way to
reconcile the causes the John and
Daenerys basically if she trusts him
again he could play a large role in
convincing her that what John is saying
is in fact true I'm sure some people out
there have already come to this
conclusion some of you guys probably did
too and the idea is probably out there
but this makes a whole lot of sense to
me and it's just something that I never
really considered before we know John's
going to go north because we've seen the
trailers but it's been bothering me
about how we might see Daenerys come
around to his cause right so of course
the wall coming down that would have
been an event that would cause her to
understand the threat and get her move
but it seems like Sonia moved that
direction of helping John before that
happened like if that's going to happen
at the end of the season or whatever
things need to move in that direction
before the idea that Jorah will be there
to move this along just seems to work
right so let me know what you guys think
about that
in the comments and if you don't think
that's why he's still around and why is
he around as a side note I guess it's
possible that he might be the one who
ends up wielding the Tarly valerian
blade heart's pain now that John has his
family's blade Longclaw and that's
obviously John now and it's not going to
go back to him I mean what would John
Snow be without Longclaw at this point
so the whole idea of them having hearts
pain that's just an idea or a guess but
it comes to mind because they made a
point of Sam stealing the blade which
was a little bit weird whatever because
that you know his father seems to have
just been okay with it I mean not okay
but he didn't go after him which is what
you would expect him to do but either
way you know Sam isn't a lawyer and
there are quite a few people in our
story who could put that to better use
than he could and Jorah is one of them
right we know that Jorah is a skilled
knight and if nothing else he's going to
be important
Narus in the coming war for the dawn in
that regard in that capacity so yeah
he's a good fighter and he's going to be
important but I think that this makes
more sense that he has a deeper meaning
just in the way that everything played
out so some other episode two and three
sings one of the things I saw the most
in the comments in the last couple of
videos was about Sansa and people
referring to her as the queen in Jon's
absence and this led a lot of people to
ponder that the title might be referring
to her I can see where you're coming
from especially since the last title not
only referred to Daenerys but to Iran as
well Stormborn is something we associate
with Daenerys but at the same time we
saw your on he was born you know he was
born in the storm he is the storm he
watched his birth as he smacked down on
Yanis deck right so yeah I get that
people are looking for that same kind of
parallel but in relation to the Queen's
justice I don't think it refers to Sansa
and you know I kind of alluded at the
beginning of the last video that we
don't know which or both and I think
that's the double thing is that we're
going to see the Queen's justice from
the two Queens it's not just about one
or the other it's about those two them
so like Santa isn't actually the queen
of the north the title isn't what Jon
bestowed on her if Jon had a wife she
would be his queen I suppose but even in
that case it doesn't mean she's like the
queen of the north when he's not around
I mean does that make sense
my speculation here is that Jon just put
her in charge of day-to-day business at
Winterfell while he's away and that
speculation comes from we've seen this
kind of thing before and that's just
sort of what happens in this world the
best comparison I can think of is when
Rob was away fighting the war of the
five kings
since bran was the next in line and the
Prince of Winterfell he was the voice of
the house right when people came they
had to see brand of course maester Luwin
did most of the heavy lifting but
technically bran was in charge we
wouldn't have called him King in the
north at that point so my guess is that
it's basically the same
bodhisattva's concern her official title
would be the lady of Winterfell and yeah
she can speak and she can make decisions
but she's not equally powerful I mean
John is still the king in the north in
some people's eyes she would only have
the name the stark name if that would be
the only thing that's really important
about her
now as Littlefinger gets his way he will
undermine John's position to the point
that Sansa can use that name to overtake
him so yeah he was he wants to undermine
John's position and chip away his power
and that way he could raise Santa up and
then her power and his eyes would be his
power as well another thing I wanted to
do address and this will be the last
thing I talk about in this video because
it's starting to get long but there's a
lot of talk about the White Walkers
walking around the wall because of the
change in the opening credit sequence
where it looks like the water is frozen
off of eastwatch-by-the-sea there and I
was going to actually make a whole video
about that and I realized it would just
be me whining and complaining so I
decided not to I decided just to mention
it here and all I have to say is yeah
I've seen it
and yeah it's frozen but the wall is
more than just a physical barrier from
all of what we've known from everything
from all the material so if they have
this idea that they're going to I
mentioned in the other video that I
would have a really hard time has John
been to me this is the other thing
that's kind of like would fundamentally
shake my faith in this television show
the wall has stood there for depending
on who you believe we'll just say that
for simplicity the wall stood there for
8,000 years could be a little bit longer
could be a lot long it could be shorter
but we're going to say that is a number
that is very large so how would they
make it an explanation that all that
really had to happen was that it would
get cold enough for the water to freeze
and then all of a sudden the wall
wouldn't matter honestly we don't know a
whole lot about why the seasons are odd
except for George or
and says that it's magic involved so not
going to go down that though you got to
imagine that 8,000 years was long enough
that if it's going to get cold enough or
there are spells that they can throw on
the water that would have already
happened and this is where it becomes
just a total rabbit hole on you can
check my video on the ball that I made
in the offseason where I talk about some
of the lore and the history on that but
bottom line is is that there's magic in
the wall and for this to be the case
that would mean that everything the
Nights Watch everything that's happened
in the entirety of our story it was all
just based on a sense of salt fall
security and so like I said they would
have to come up with a really good
explanation now there are lots of
different theories out there about why
the White Walkers all the sudden wants
to come south the obvious is that the
magic is picking up in the world and
that you know dragons have been reborn
and in the books there's a lot of other
stuff that's pointing to magic making
leaps and bounds as far as different
things which I won't get into but yeah
so they could be responding to that but
at the same time Aegon came to Westeros
not that long ago in the history of
things and he had dragons they didn't
sidestep the wall will not happen and
like I said there's more rabbit hole
stuff here the children you know what
happened at the end of last season
they're not supposed to be able to go
into that weirwood and they did and all
that's just we don't have anything to
compare that to because it's not in the
books but yeah I really don't like the
idea that of them just being able to go
around the wall I wouldn't have any
problem with it if it froze and that
made it harder to defend the wall things
along those lines but I feel like they
have to figure out a way to make that
wall fall in order for that to be a
workable story but we'll see how it
plays out so yeah I rambled way longer
than I wanted to on that I'll cut it off
here please like this video if you
enjoyed it and please subscribe to my
channel
I've been putting out quite a few Game
of Thrones videos and I'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments please
follow me over on Twitter and on my
other social media accounts and thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon